you know medicine some medicine are are
bitter at the bitter you know it's it's
not pleasant
yeah after when you when you start to
feel the effect the pleasant effect of
killing the cure here coming yes now
then then you realize that you were sick
and now you are getting healthy at that
cure is good for you and you like it you
love it where the juice juice bar here
nothing but beautiful juices healthy
alternative I mean the right way to go
ahead and put the right things in your
body and we got a brother here we're
gonna ask a very important question what
turns you out to Islam
what turns you out is actually thinking
about the purpose of life to now you're
actually practicing the purpose of life
in the Dean before like six years ago I
came to this point in my life where I
started to think about the purpose of
life and me and my good friend why you
know and we started to
to investigate
a lot of aspects of philosophy the some
theories of a lot of people who do the
research about the community in all
different levels and after some time we
came across Islamic view on life and
coming from
muslin background as a
[Music]
my family I didn't practice as long I
did a little bit as a kid
[Music]
it was very very interesting to me to
start learning about something that was
part of my family history and my
my history as a whole as a person
because you know everybody called us
Muslims around us people who weren't
Muslims we used to call our Muslims
among ourselves we used to even
celebrate eats Byrom's Asma : and so on
but it was all all of it was a something
I didn't quite understand and folklore
because part of all time but then we as
we went into into it we reached some
some informations that we didn't know
before like we always look me in my
throat my my brother's why we always
believed in God and the creator and when
we talked about it we never denied it
and we it was clear to us that this
creator was one it was really simple to
us we accepted it very quick but then we
came to to Quran the Quran we started to
find out about Quran you know what it is
it is represented as a direct word from
the Creator passed through angel Gabriel
to his final messenger to humanity
Muhammad SAW Allah Allah
[Music]
and then after we went into this
knowledge about Quran we start to find
out that Quran is full of information
which could not be known by a simple
Shepard from the seventh century
or to be exact Shepard who used to live
almost
1,500 years of information about
universe expanding about the planets
being in the in moving into orbit even
the Sun which was absolutely not known
at the time as we found out before yeah
then we came across the development of
embryo in mother's womb exact stages of
development alario and also which was
very interesting this one one thing
about the history like Egyptian
hieroglyphs were not known at the time
it was a dead language
it was deciphered I don't know maybe a
hundred years ago 150 years ago by some
I'm not sure French scientists so the
the hieroglyphs or the ancient Egyptian
language was dead at the time of the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu sorry but
Quran talks about the rulers of Egypt in
the time of ibrahim alaih-is-salaam and
Quran talks about the rulers of Egypt in
the time of moses or musa alehsalaam and
the Quran talks about the rulers having
a different titles rulers of Egypt at
the time of ibrahim alaih-is-salaam
what is called his title is kingly while
ruler of in the time of Musa al-salaam
is referred as Pharaoh historians
thought that Egyptian rulers were was
were always called Pharaoh's never Kings
until hieroglyphs or ancient Egyptian
language was deciphered around I don't
know maybe fit 150 years ago when this
knowledge was uncovered that means
rulers of Egypt at the time of ibrahim
alaih-is-salaam were indeed called kings
and in the in the time of Musa lives
among so to keep it not to go into the
information in the Quran one after
another led me to be convinced that this
comes from the source
other than a man the source of from the
source who knows it all and that source
can only be God God were Allah for
originator of the heavens in the earth
possesses all the knowledge and this
came to a conclusion that this could be
only from that source so when I when I
was convinced convinced about that then
I came to this other conclusion that if
I trust this source I trust this source
with the other things and those other
things were I have to establish Salah or
prayer I have to do things which it
where he tells me to do and avoid things
which he tells me to avoid even if I
didn't like it at the beginning it was
strange to me because I grew up and I
got accustomed to a different things but
I was convinced this comes from
something supernatural something which
is all-powerful all-knowing
and I had to submit to this source and
when I started to practice Islam were
these Commandments and advices and to
absorb these informations which are
which were given to me at the time
immediately I started to feel peace in
my life too to
at first before piece to fill purpose of
my life why am I here and it was a
tremendous joy to feel to feel the to
come to the purpose of your life
to finally find find out and to be
convinced not only to believe but to be
convinced why why are we here why are we
living here and why are we dying but
everything is explained everything makes
sense
and Allah says in the Quran I have not
made jinn where mankind except to
worship the worship what advice do you
have for other people who are seeking
that peace that you have now in Islam
and who are seeking purpose and they're
listening to you they might be serving
in Croatia from the Balkans what advice
do you have for the world out there my
advice if there are seeking for the
truth sincerely this they should they
should first of all when I before I
started to come to Islam I did I did
believe in God I did believe in God and
I did ask him to guide you so that maybe
to them it sounds maybe they don't want
to do it maybe don't they don't believe
in God right now but to those who do
even to those who don't think about it
think about it think about the creation
think about all of this everything has a
purpose around you even given this
sweater
that's a purpose so if you think you
don't have a purpose this sweater has a
purpose think again you know and you
will come to the conclusion after a
sincere
the reflection upon it you will come to
the conclusion that there is a God there
is a creator and if you are sincere and
you want to guidance to the truth ask
him ask him to guide you and I'm sure he
will
that's my advice and even if you some
things if you don't like them at the
beginning you shouldn't go to what I
like and don't like but go for what is
true and what is false go for for the go
for the truth the proof what is the
evidence what does it prove the things
that guides you to the truth not not not
the things that you know goes with your
with your passions and desires or what
not I like it I don't like it this is
what what got me into this one I mean
some some stuff at the beginning I
didn't quite understand I didn't like it
it was hard but I knew it was true and
after a while you know medicine some
medicine are are better at the better
you know it it's not
pleasant yeah but after when you when
you start to feel the effect the
pleasant effect of cooling the cure a
cure coming yes now then then you
realize that you were sick now you are
getting healthy that cure is good for
you and you like it you love it as long
as they're curious and guess that
medicine for the heart for the soul and
we'll leave you with that homework ask
ask the crater alone the one who credits
you for guidance asked me why am I here
what's my purpose to be sincere and
genuine courageous to go ahead and
continue investigating with the reliance
on the one who created you with no
intermediaries no secretary in the
middle just the one guy the one creator
we'll see you next time peace be with
you Salaam alaikum